well well well it's off the mother
loving rails
number ten
jeff bezos
no crashing just gunfire this time
the crashing was somewhere in there too
it's getting a little off and it's hard
to hard to tell the bezos laugh uh will
live on it's off the rails jack not
world war three
[Music]
only number 10 i mean my goodness it
feels like we've been doing this forever
well since we officially started calling
it off the rails right
well we are off the rails and boy do we
have a great great show for you guys
sponsored by ting
it's just ting tings
and also listen
presenting sponsor is mommy
look at this shirt bro
so nice teddyfresh.com you guys heard
about it and not a big deal just my
wife's company
ceo
entrepreneur
born in
1987
doesn't quite rhyme the same
look at this stuff guys
let me highlight some stuff look at this
floral nana's couch was ripped up
and made into a hoodie all right
i know it's hot it's kind of not really
hoody weather but you know it's cold
today it will be soon yeah
it's certainly it certainly will be soon
you know
these bags are amazing too i've heard
really good reviews about these bags
they're made of pvc which is this really
shiny
cool material you all know what it is
right
and then
what else we got mommy
the paisley hoodie we've been over
saying it like that mommy no
it's gross milk mommy
what the hell what's gross about mommy
milky talking about your wife daddy
yeah she's mommy
this is the shirt i'm wearing right now
in case you're wondering
anyway there you go head on over
teddyfresh.com see if there's something
you like okay thank you
dude i'll be honest i'm so freaking
angry right now about
first of all our last
channel
or not a last year the video we made on
monday which was doing phenomenally and
everybody was really enjoying
got [ __ ] blocked no guys i'm just
gonna vent here for a minute
blocked worldwide first four hour
podcast right we did a long
extensive podcast excruciatingly long
guess how long the this part was i
can't guess because i know seven [ __ ]
seconds
seven seconds
yeah of a four hour podcast now here's
my problem
i think youtube's done a pretty good job
of like returning the rights to the
creators and so i applaud them but this
worldwide block and i'm going to explain
briefly why this is the most nefarious
tool ever given
by license holder rats
okay so to remove a video traditionally
you have to file what's known as a dmca
it's a legal document that says
i
i certify that i've considered fair use
and i've determined that uh it doesn't
mean it and i'm going to remove this
video it's a legal document that has
legal consequences nobody uses dmc's
anymore why because they have the tool
from youtube worldwide block worldwide
block is more effective and there's
literally no recourse at all to using it
so they blocked my
they blocked my entire podcast for seven
seconds and my two uh usually with the
dmca i can be like yo [ __ ] you this is
fair use and guess what the video goes
back up immediately
worldwide block i have two options
one snip it out
and once it's done processing
it gets reinstated we snipped it out
guess how long it's been like 30 [ __ ]
hours and it's not ups yeah we caught it
when it was blocked pretty much
immediately because we just happened to
see a post somebody complaining about it
right as it happened
and yeah i mean that was around this
time yesterday so it's been about 24
hours and it's still not finished doing
its thing
dude
you know and then the other option is
that you can dispute it and say yo no
actually this is fair use or whatever
that doesn't automatically reinstate the
video that takes a week a week
yeah so it's like
their system is it gives no benefit of
the doubt to the creator and it's like
this unlimited power to shut down videos
with no legal repercussions at all for
the license holders worldwide block is
dog [ __ ] and youtube needs to do
something about it ugh it's so awkward
you know
i don't know why they allow that [ __ ]
yeah i don't get dmcas anymore
just worldwide blocks
outrageous bro so upsetting anyway if
you guys were mid watching the um h3tv
it will be back up
hopefully today probably by the time
this show goes up it should be done and
this whole discussion will be moot
yeah you know last night it finished
processing
and then like the processing didn't work
i'm like okay well i waited 12 hours
so i had to re-snip it and now i'm just
hoping it works this time
yeah
very upsetting
and you know i i spent my career
fighting for fair use and creators
rights and this just circumvents
everything
why is it that i can't get my work my
creative work
back up on youtube immediately
if i say yo this is [ __ ] why do they
get the benefit of the doubt
i'm proven guilty
assumed guilty
you know
pissed
anyway [ __ ] them
all right let's move on i just want to
give update because a lot of people were
wondering where the podcast went so
there you have it
all right now i'm being outed by the
crew
yeah i'm being outed
i have not looked at this but
you want to set this up i mean they
i've been accused of leaving fruit
around the office yeah so the wider
context to this is we
we have a fly problem
okay i think it's been discussed a
little bit on the show you've probably
seen that we have that bug assault
salt shooter cannon or whatever and
that's because there are gnats and flies
in this office constantly
and
it's been a raging debate
amongst the crew you think my fruit is
bringing
i don't think
i'm fl
there's i'm not coming with flat with
larvae hatched fruit dan you i think
you're half correct it's half the fruit
and the other half is the dog [ __ ]
yeah the dog [ __ ] doesn't bring fruit
into the our flies how does that work
the flies have to be here
to feast on the [ __ ]
they're being what came first the flies
are the [ __ ] they're being attracted by
something oh you think they can smell
this [ __ ] from outside i guess
we are not arguing spontaneous
generation monday there was smeared [ __ ]
by the front door so someone stopped
actually you know that yeah i wanted to
add something to the doc before but i
forgot let me just grab something real
quick i'll be right back
okay well while ab gets whatever that is
is it a picture of your fruit sitting
out there right now because you probably
did it well that's fresh fruit you can't
blame me for leaving that yeah
oh it sure is you can't blame me for
fruit that i haven't even left yet look
look what was out there
i just got here
it's left open with no top do you see
flies in it not yet yeah leave it here
overnight
that's the thing too so yeah some
additional context you want it
i'll take my fruit thank you
it's oftentimes left
after ethan takes off for the day thank
you um and at the end of the day there
is i accept
for i clearly accept the responsibility
of leaving the fruit the fruit line is
is damaging everything making it all
worse
tim tim is right on this one is right on
this he is right
i accept the fruit
that it's not nice to leave fruit out
okay
right
i got to take care of my own mess
and sometimes things are moving fast i
get here we start i gotta leave because
theodore
the fruit the fruit sometimes stays
sometimes
okay
but what i don't accept is that it's a
breed become a breeding ground
for insects there's a [ __ ] there's a
fly
buzzing mountain
[Applause]
why is there a picture of a garbage man
it's just one picture of fruit you guys
that's your evidence
your evidence is one picture of fruit
what was the garbage man it's just the
next imager meme oh yeah i thought it
was a
little you guys are doing an expose and
there's one picture it's a yeah it's a
single example oh my god this is you're
gonna have to take our word for it that
this has been an ongoing
thing
i cannot believe you guys come at me
with one picture of fruit i wouldn't
talk too much [ __ ] because i guarantee
we'll get you again
i can't leave it
i thought you were going to have like 20
pictures of fruit and do a whole expose
well we could have but okay so you
didn't
listen i'm refuting at all now i'll say
i left fruit once
it's too late i left fruit one it's all
on the record
we've got you can watch one video can
you say it for the sun bite
say what i already said it zach don't
try me
i left fruit once
um
only one time as that's all you can
prove your honor we can piece the sound
bite together from various things that's
okay doesn't take a rocket surgeon ethan
a rocket's vision
anyway okay i was expecting to get
roasted harder for the fruit thing it's
this is more this isn't a roast this is
an intervention
one picture bro
you know
you know there's more
and we roast because we love
uh what do we got oh heather
heather from the last deleted episode or
not deleted blocked [ __ ] episode
uh jake paul got me again by the way can
we reflect on the flag that jake paul
got me again
yeah i mean
i've been seeing some chatter on the
subreddit and stuff of people saying
they weren't surprised by this
boxing is notoriously uh listen
aggressive with uh it's blocking i i'm
not surprised either but what i am
surprised about is like that our
coverage and commentary was fair it was
minimal usage like i said it was seven
seconds of a four-hour podcast i mean
what what's unacceptable is that
youtube doesn't give us better tools to
protect ourselves because
you know why should why should we just
not talk about stuff if it's fair use
that's that's not like
that's not right wouldn't it
i guess there are circumstances where
this would maybe cause more trouble but
i almost feel like it would be better if
they
by claiming it it just it
what it what we're waiting on right now
for the processing the snipping if that
just automatically happened when they
did the claim just take it out of the
episode temporarily and then we can
dispute it but don't block the episode
wouldn't that be a better solution for
everybody i think that's a great
solution for us but for for most people
they make like 10 minute videos and
sometimes it's like two three four five
minutes right so then there's like half
the app missing and it's like i guess it
doesn't make any sense yeah
um this is an update from heather the
infamous
girl from uh who won the thousand
dollars from the lord of the flies
he gave me a shout out ethan pays on
time ladies and gentlemen the thousand
dollars
get your heart out cut i'm just some
dude and i [ __ ] paid
it's so awesome that uh that happened
i'm still blown away that she happened
to be a fan happened to be watching me
too that was incredible i love when that
[ __ ] happens she like she messaged me on
discord and i'm like she's like oh it's
heather from the video and i'm like oh
okay here we go you know
i'm like
i was kind of rude up front so i
apologize i'm like prove it
no you did the right thing i mean you
you know we don't but i saw chatter back
there and i was like hmm i wonder what's
going on i saw like a b and dan going on
peeking in zach because i wanted to
verify it i didn't want to cut in yeah
and be wrong about it but um yeah i mean
she sent irrefutable proof it was her so
there you go
so shout out to heather and she was in
the discord too which i
i wonder if she already was a member
even
could be love her yeah i think she was
lovely shout out to heather
oh you know what i want to do today
um i want to say first of all thank you
to our members i never thanked them
enough or at least during these shows
you guys being members makes this show
so much more
sustainable for us
dependable you know uh revenue
why are you laughing
because of music not not what you're
saying
i'm not laughing at the members i love
the members just zach playing the sappy
music i thought you're laughing at our
members hell no you disrespecting no
i'm good luck i'm the champion of the
members
i'm the i'm the member's
scion dan's a good man that's right you
beautiful you beautiful
people
who uh have members of the channel it
means so much and uh
thank you so much and also this is
something i never do but
i've i was looking at our back end
there's like 40 of the people that watch
the show who are not subscribed
[Music]
how's that work
well if you watch a channel on a video
enough times even if you're not
subscribed youtube will be like uh push
it to you
yeah it's like a virtual subscription i
guess what do you know 40 of you out
there click that click that subscribe
button guys come on
just one click please i need to stick it
to the haters
we need those subbies going up so that
the haters go
sad
five percent means everything we got
about three million subs
forty percent of that i mean we're
talking like nearly five percent
difference over a million people yeah
it's astronomical the forty percent
probably is majority of the haters
yeah you think that many people watch
they hate me i just hate watching 40
percent hate watching holy [ __ ]
i think everyone that majority of people
who don't like you were a fan or still
are a fan and act like they are bag of
turret you know that's for sure
the majority of people that don't
dislike me
are
people who used to think i was one of
them i think a lot of it is because
like i've talked about i used to make
these kind of
anti-sjw videos on h3 mm-hmm and um
[Music]
i almost there was a point there was a
crossroad where it's like i can get i
can become tin pool
and get lost in the sauce
or
i can be true to myself
shake these uh you know i don't want
these intel's red-pilled guy i mean they
actually i do want i want everybody to
watch don't get me wrong but like
i don't want the world i don't want to
signal
that i'm a red pellet insole red palled
your blue pill is [ __ ] up
so i think a lot of those people are
still angry at me
don't get over it
they will never get over for years
anyway let's get on with some funny
stuff
[Applause]
even crowder used to be a fan of mine
apparently
well the the truth is
there was this one a few videos i made
that were going viral on the internet
back in the day i would tweet it out and
i would see people like dave
i would see like a dave rubin i would
see crowder i would see mike cernovich
all these people where i was like oh
gag see them what
retweeting quote tweeting oh i see
amazed right amazing video
right and then i was like oh my god that
was kind of my wake-up call was like oh
my god
am i the baddie weird mike
shout out to weird mike
oh my god anyway um let's get into some
fun stuff
dude this video is a legend [ __ ]
so this is a school board
they're doing roll call
and this dude is literally mo from the
simpsons he gets conned
and just saying so many fake names
that
i mean
you can't write this stuff i mean you
can't but you're thinking
phil mccracken
phil mccracken and the way he just fires
them off why
sulk souk
souk what
mighty
medic soup
suck my dick
[Music]
ophelia mccock
i leaned over i leaned over bro what the
[ __ ] eileen doler
don kiddick wait so what's that one don
that's my donkey dick donkey dick
don
that's
[Laughter]
[Music]
don kiddig
wayne kerr
wanker
wayne kerr
phil mccracken
phil mccracken
it's back to the beginning
so feel my cracking you really you don't
actually get stuff that good usually in
real life no
no just boom boom boom right after the
other yeah i mean it was a it was the
public comment section of the um of the
council meeting and you know anybody can
sign up
to speak
but for some reason don keatick wasn't
there uh or or ben
or no
i leaned over that's right i leaned over
this is like some stern level [ __ ] man
i love that
just
hi i'm dick tiff
yeah it said uh that was three hours
into the agenda i guess he was fatigued
when it arrived at the public comments
forum
only one person actually went up to
speak
of all the people he called
uh we've also got a little update to our
mlk story how fortnite added
uh an mlk martin luther king jr event
which there was some debate about some
people said you know they appreciate the
effort but overwhelming i think people
concluded that it was inappropriate
because you saw like people just
whipping
on the statue
fortnite it was a whole mess you know
and there was like rick
rick and morty rick and morty rick rick
rick rick
all up on mlk
and so you know in an effort
to get on top of this
epic games has disabled
in-game emojis for players as we
suggested emotes yeah emotes yeah
fortnite and so
um
there was however one emote
that they for some reason
[Music]
left activated
it is known as whiplash
the emote remained active some fans
believe it has something to do with some
contractual obligation to dc comics
apparently did a collaboration with
wonder woman or something no it was
actually catwoman okay i saw people
speculating well yeah she has a whip
yeah but worse is was catwoman in a
movie or recently what the [ __ ] is that
popular character from
i'm pretty sure
that dc would have been okay with them
uh uh disabling this during the mlk
tribute
yeah
so here it is
so guys in case you're wondering what's
the one emote
that you can use during the mlk tribute
civil rights greatest civil great civil
rights leader
it is
um
of course cracking a whip ladies oh my
god it is cracking away it's so bad
yes it is it's just there's one emoji
and it's cracking
the whip fortnite they have some very
basic ones i believe you can still use
just to clarify like i believe the
clapping one but
a few other ones some respectful ones
respectful ones but in terms of like
dancing or
ones that have a lot of uh
movement i believe this is the only one
yeah i mean of all the ones that were
there like the nene and whatever dancing
i mean this is clearly the most racist
and offensive one i guess i can't
imagine a more offensive one short of
just than the nazi salute being in
oh jesus
i guess we should probably just for our
non-american listeners that may not be
familiar with american history but um
you know whips are
in in relation to slavery
uh are
sort of symbolic of slave drivers they
would use whips on
uh black slaves in the fields to to
drive them to work harder as if they
were animals essentially so this is
particularly offensive uh
of all the things they could have left
in this this probably is yeah and what
what's what's fascinating to me is like
if you're gonna remove all the emojis
and leave one you're going to draw way
more attention to the one that you do
leave yes you were better off just
leaving them all it probably would have
been better just let them keep i'd wait
rather see a whipping nae nae
than a [ __ ] whip bro
so bad it's horrific
they really couldn't have
botched this any harder it's
unbelievable yeah i heard they're
actually going to be um
they're going to be including another
emoji for just for this event of picking
cotton so you're right
yeah
some people are finding that offensive i
did find it very inappropriate for
tonight
yeah yeah there's going to be um
i heard they're going to put on an event
the of uh the the slave auction they're
gonna have a whole wow they're gonna
just have an event where you auction off
slaves what are they doing over there
right now
appropriate yeah totally absolutely
insane my god
uh and then so
there's more wrinkles than this the
kinks you know apparently they obviously
they licensed it but i don't know how
what process goes into that
because the king
martin luther king jr center put out a
statement as did his daughter which i'll
read the king center does not license dr
king's intellectual property and
therefore was not involved in any
decision concerning the endeavors with
time inc
oh no time was involved in this [ __ ]
yeah they were the main kind of sponsors
for this thing there was a big times
like sign in the game yeah i remember
when when the master chief was being
teleported into uh into washington dc he
was going through a time magazine cover
that's why
these licensing decisions are made by
intellectual properties management yeah
of course dude so
there's nothing better to ruin your
state than put some
mindless [ __ ] ip company in charge of
your [ __ ] well so that night i did a
little investigating and that company is
run
essentially
the children of mlk
uh have been fighting
over
this for years and so that intellectual
property company is run by one of his
sons
um
who
is very eager to
auction off his legacy at any time
yeah he's looking to make that back so
his daughter said decisions around
licensing my father's intellect probably
are outside my personal preview okay so
one of his one of his heirs was involved
in the one of the heirs was involved um
yeah and yeah there's sort of some
history to this i guess the
uh
the daughter and the son have been
fighting over
selling out his legacy for a while now
well his legacy is protected do not
worry
it's immortalized and
fortnite is on it
um fortnite
and uh that's really so we we applaud
fortnite certainly for the whip cracking
the whip cracking
like you said i mean dc is certainly
said do you yeah go ahead and remove it
maybe like [ __ ] no we have a contract
[ __ ]
i demand the whip cracks be in the
mlk tribute
how about just take it out and then if
they try to like sue you or something
they'll look like big [ __ ] yeah
right just take it out and be like yo
you understand
weird
man here's a suggestion just don't be
[ __ ] weird weird decisions were made
on that one
so a little update for you there you
know
um we are not quite at 30 but we're
almost there all right well our next i
just set us up so you know
i would do the next segment you guys
aren't going to want to miss
it's well you know what let's just go to
a break we all you guys have seen this
on tick tock this has 4.5 million likes
brad
so it's like sexy arresting
thirst traps it's super weird so we're
gonna watch these and we're gonna make
our own so stay tuned we'll be right
back after the short commercial break
time to take a short break thank you
thank you
this video was brought to you by
h3.ting.com
it's the next generation of team mobile
whether you're a low data user or need
unlimited ting has the perfect plan for
you and your family get talk and text
for just ten dollars a month you get
data from fifteen dollars five gigabytes
for 25 12 gigabyte gigabytes for 35 and
you can get unlimited data for just
45 per month
check out their plan and see how much
you could be saving
everything else you expect from team
mobile remains the same they've got the
unreal customer service the nationwide
coverage no contracts and top-notch
account tools plus
you can always bring your current phone
and phone number to ting with no strings
attached try team today
and get a 25 credit at h3.ting.com
oh oh choose smarter choose ting so guys
once again bring your phone and get 25
off at h3.ting.com try ting mobile with
the 25 service credit at ting.com dot
daytree.ting.com h3.ting.com
25
boom boom boom
yeah so
this video
i don't under this trend is like really
popular and
i gotta say i don't get it
the vibe is also one of kind of like
this guy less so but like there's kind
of an essay vibe to it as well how they
get tossed oh you'll see in the other
ones it kind of i'm like what is
actually happening here
um i guess it's just like the bad boy
thing
he's so bad
but like what he's so bad i guess that's
it i mean i i don't know what else to
say about it
oh no let me see the views because it
says form that's gonna be oh this guy's
super popular 49 million views
you guys
holy [ __ ] let's get glam
holy [ __ ] dude
someone said i think it's a nice time
for this trend to come to an end
trying to get some insight in the
comments here but i'm not really
armin does it better
yeah
so he's hot as [ __ ] and he doesn't give
a [ __ ]
he's going to jail what did he do i
wonder hmm
wait
i just noticed the person doing the
arrest is in uh military fatigues oh my
this is actually he's a warrior he's a
political prisoner oh my god oh
i love how they're going all out with
the props but he left the ring light in
his hand as he arrests him wait really
yeah look at it right here watch when he
pushes look see it no those are the
that's the handcuffs oh it's reflecting
off okay yeah you break the i'm how dare
you break the wall
he's not really getting arrested i'm how
dare you a b i wasn't wrong in twilight
movies i do
so that's this one 50 million
oh geez here's another one
these thirst traps are just kind of the
best hot people tick tock is so out of
control you guys
um you are arrested
oh no
oh he's got the letterman jacket and
everything so hot
so
[ __ ] hot dude he's got a bandana on
he's not wearing a shirt
i love you oh my god it's his it's his
final farewell
as he goes to a political prison to get
waterboarded he's going to guantanamo
and someone at the top of this he's
definitely never been arrested yet
why is he wearing a letterman jacket
with no shirt underneath
i'm kind of curious about that as [ __ ]
danny is that him i'm just not i'm not
i'm not a hot guy yeah i don't know what
you are i don't want to hear you talking
and not not hot enough not that hot not
that hot i don't see him cruise around
letterman jacket with no shirt and yeah
i don't even own a letterman jacket
catch a vibe dude he's a varsity douche
so
somebody said were you getting it from
behind and i know it's uncute but that's
that's kind of like
i don't know why i just feel like
there's some insinuation that it's just
a little too rough
wow sister snapped
yeah hot as [ __ ] bro how many views does
that one have that is a hundred thousand
hundred thousand hundred thousand likes
so probably a million views
oh that's pathetic that last guy
compared million that last guy's the
king of this [ __ ] buddy but this guy is
being arrested by the cops the last guy
like i said is a military prisoner yeah
two million that's definitely hotter
yeah that's two million views so
congratulations but that
no don't congratulate him for that
dude i gotta tell you
i was browsing tick tock over the
weekend
and i saw a video
of a dude
straight up with his dick out in his
hand
and it had been up all day no [ __ ]
way oh
and everyone and all the comments were
like what the hell is going on it was a
dude with his
erect penis in his hand on tick tock up
for a whole day it showed up on your
head like 20 000 likes for you paige
yeah i was on my for you page i couldn't
believe what i was seeing
that's because they're pretty
they're pretty locked down
i make i'm whisper one bad thing about
james charles and they removed that in
like five seconds yeah i mean how many
times have you been suspended from tick
tock now
i've never been suspended but i get oh
my videos always go down wait
no
they just occasionally crush his
algorithms yeah like they stopped him
from doing like uh duets at one point
but yeah
yeah they turned off my duet
i'm all i'm rehabilitated
dude i got a community strike just a few
days ago
because this dude
i wonder if i can show it
this dude if you got a strike probably
not
well no it's fine here but this dude did
a prank where he like stuck he was like
at shopping at walmart or whatever and
he turned around and stuck
a mop handle up a girl's
employees like bum
and this video had like 20 million views
it was up for a week
and i make a reaction to it where laura
was like i would had a mop in my hand
and then i'm in jail
okay and they removed it for harassment
and bowling
harassment and bowling and here's a guy
with a cut with his [ __ ] in his hand you
guys i [ __ ] you not
it's them sister snipers i believe james
charles has a team watching you at all
times ready to report you oh
that's crazy did you ask him about it
when you saw him at the mall maybe yeah
yeah i said did you sister snipe ethan
he's like i don't know he's like
charles
so that's that one
yeah but i was just thinking about
because someone asked on families if
they should let their eight-year-old
browse tick-tock and
i don't know man i saw a dude with a
butt with his erect wee-wee in his hand
i was blown away by that dick tips
i'm so curious do you remember if there
was hashtags
i don't think i don't i don't remember
why does that matter
a few reasons
i don't use hashtags on my on my one
that got bullying and harassment because
if he cause like the algorithm on tick
tock's really smart about how they push
stuff so i'm curious like sometimes when
people just want the best growth they'll
do the top three hashtags so i'm just
curious if that dick got dispersed to
random
people he had a lot of growth from one
hearing it didn't have those clickbaity
like shop at walmart hashtag shop at
walmart yeah no it didn't have that
he has a massive penis ian ian you saw
it
chill dude yeah tick tock is wild man i
don't know
here's another one three million likes
so this one's pretty viral as well
oh [ __ ] he's oh he's got it oh he's
having fun though yeah roughed up
this is uh this is like the wildest
trend since the fake holocaust survivor
all right
he's like smiling while
while crying somehow is this like uh
why do they all have the same haircut
too well at least the last two dude
this is like
i'm a lesbian and i don't understand
what's going on in this video well
i don't think you have to be alive yeah
i don't know if your sexuality uh
would help explain it
my question is is anyone actually thirst
trapping her or is it all just like
intrigue how bizarre this is i mean
there's
three million
likes you have to imagine
at least i never liked it that's the
thing i would never like it
even if i watched it
let me try i'm trying to find the views
on this smash that like button
here's one with
six million from the same creator let's
see what he's up to
yeah third strap nation bruh
oh my god how did he do that
how did he do that dude you're like 12.
what the [ __ ]
shouldn't you be in school or something
he doesn't look 12.
he looks young
i can't deal with this
you know what this reminds me of is the
mug shot challenge do you remember that
one on tick tock vaguely james charles
did it actually
oh pull it up oh james charles did a mug
shot challenge he's that fantasy's gonna
become reality for him soon the way he's
going oh no i sent him the discord also
cam just uh sent me a preview of tick
tock is doing some rebranding
recently oh it's like uh oh okay that
looks familiar that's accurate
yeah
yeah i mean the nature of tick tock of
just how people upload [ __ ] and so if
some for some reason it doesn't dude are
you [ __ ] kidding me james charles
right now hold on take me out to the
back of the shed shoot me in the back of
the head
take me out
dude
i cannot believe you did this you freak
his makeup looks good
like his black eye makeup maybe it's not
makeup and he's just trying to cover up
yeah
that's what would happen to him if he
was flirting with my six-year-old son
[Music]
on snapchat and labeled as a predator
easy in minecraft in minecraft
well he's well well i i know yeah it's
all theoretical they were actually 16.
they were actually what was that james
they were actually 16. that's not good
that's not good at all
that's it's horrible to admit
so
embarrassing yeah did you see james
charles actually going to the met gala
is that confirmed because i could see
mixed things they they released a
seating chart but then i saw people
saying it was fake
oh really this chart was fake okay thank
you guys i had i looked into that deeply
because it was all over yeah yeah
get the memo on this guy i mean
but is he invited
is that confirmed
i don't
know that for sure let me check okay
actually i heard he's he's um
actually i heard he's uh auditioning
he's in training to become a priest so
he's he's choosing a better path for
himself oh good yeah
he's
yeah
that's good the catholic church is open
to him with uh open arms or catholic
right yeah yes catholic yeah so or and
if that doesn't work out i heard he's uh
he's he's training to become a scout
leader actually oh that's good i'm
definitely i'm glad he's choosing a
better path right
giving back to the community he's giving
back to the community he's repenting we
love that for him
another one
oh god he's so hot and he's just in so
much distress oh this is so unfortunate
it looks like he checked himself out on
the hood for a second
he's like god saw the reflection
oh you're right yeah
did he let me see that he needed a last
minute glance yeah he's like the [ __ ]
i'm sorry you see how rough they're
being with them like this one is maybe
the most realistic so far
oh yeah he took a little bit
he licked his lips at himself
yeah this is i guess girls want to role
play having a inmate for a spouse oh
this guy's in fatigues too what what
kind of resistance group are these guys
all uh part of yeah i think it's all the
same people as what's going on it's the
same click probably yeah
here's the last one before we get to
uh
our special little surprise here
oh no he's in the car
dude
wait isn't that like a honda civic or
something
well don't criticize too much until you
see ours it's it's also hang on hang on
hang on is that an accord
undercover dude
just real quick in regards to the matt
gala the official list hasn't been
released yet thank god oh that was all
rumor mongering
so let's read some so the people here
love him he says i love you
me on the toilet i don't get that is
that
i think the look that he gives at the
end is like
glad i'm a lesbian i see that a lot
oh another yeah
this remind uh
wow
yeah this is real thirst trust [ __ ]
there's trap [ __ ]
so you know and because this trend is so
popular i mean 50 million views we want
to get a piece of the action absolutely
so we thought hey we're i mean we're
cute boys like zach was saying well
dan i don't want to hear this self bash
[ __ ] you're a handsome [ __ ] guy
owning it right he's right
right now say i'm handsome no i'm not
saying that say it yeah i don't know
what i said this morning
i'm serious what i put on this beanie i
looked in the mirror and go god damn i
wish i could rock it like dan
beautiful blue eyes just the combination
you have big beautiful eyes too not
those not them blues
not the baby blues actually dan has been
getting a lot of thirst i've been seeing
some a lot of years for you lately yes
people are thirsting for you
don't lie you've seen it
beauty and the brain you've seen it
people are thirsting for you oh my god
ali is a very lucky woman
i'm a very lucky man
oh what a sweetheart your your your
girlfriend's awesome i'm gonna she is
i'm gonna come
anyway speaking of which let's start
with dance because he's such a hot boy
uh dan
we made our own version of course of
these arrests their
which you can watch on tick tock
so here's dan being arrested in his
thirst strap oh i can play the music
here right we got our own royalty free
version dude you got big-ass chains bro
let's go
[Music]
oh no
get that ham back there what are you
doing
so what were you arrested for
[Music]
what was i arrested for
i that's a good question for uh forging
your report card oh right right right
yeah
like
that caught up with me yo yo good bro
that chain is fire thanks thanks bro
checking yourself out i don't think so
you're under arrest
um yeah i predict millions for that one
get act you were zapp was arrested for
[ __ ] on someone's lawn yes which i
do believe is probably a crime actually
i think that there's some
legitimacy to this charge but here we go
zach you're in trouble buddy toilet
paper you know how to use it
you
that's so gross
he said check for corn for people who
didn't see
and what exactly are people supposed to
check for corn for
i'm telling the cops to check for corn
it was a healthy dump you want you yeah
okay
so you're still proud of it even though
you're being arrested absolutely man
fight the power see i initially
interpreted that you were saying you've
got the wrong guy check for corn check
for coins no i'm proud of myself it's
revolutionary now he's saying
peep
he's confessing you got it dude
a b arrested for visiting his ex-wife
what the hell does that mean
i
look and find out
sounds scandalous
[Music]
oh wait a minute oh
i get it
i don't get it he's a twitter world this
is yours he's oj he's got the glove on
he's got the golf clubs arrested for
visiting his ex-wife
for murdering your his ex that's the
implication
[Music]
a little dated
[Music]
we were working with the props we had
here in the office i don't know we had
five minutes
didn't you just says oj you're just
wearing yeah you're old o.j it was ela's
oj outfit from uh from halloween
two two years ago even longer probably
um arrested by kanye mods ian
[Music]
disliked donda and the kanye mods came
after him
high crimes here high crimes
oh noah light six that's that's a good
rating oh it's fantano
[Music]
kawaii that ain't going to cut it bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
they really came through for a light 60
that's like a good score
they came from me i got a threatening
message
you want to talk about that
uh a few years ago i was named honorary
moderator of the kanye subreddit on
reddit which you can you can go check my
name is there
for now and there's not many there's
only like five mods so yeah it's a big
subreddit too there's like over a half a
million people on there so in the group
it's surprising that they uh
let me do that but i got a message
yesterday that said
after your comments on dondo we will
have to rethink your position
as a moderator
on the kanye subreddit
so we had a little bit of a negotiations
and yeah i wish you the best
that must have been heart-wrenching to
hear that they
that they were doubting you in that
regard i didn't realize how far i've
fallen in the community
but i mean your comments weren't even
bad i i was the one that like for
example if you go to our highlight clip
i thought this was funny oh the like
ratio oh now it's like sixty percent
down
yeah there you go
i have a [ __ ] opinion
with that title though this is gonna
piss some off
i just mean up front i wasn't like
dania's trash [ __ ] all you
you guys you said pretty much the first
half of that
the big criticism they had was you
saying that it wasn't a diverse album
okay
but uh
you know that was it
there's a
big argument that could be made but i
don't know if i want to make it
in regards to the kanye mods
unless ian you have anything to say do
you mind if i make the argument well
i i uh
stated my case to the moderators and
they um
after some brutal talks
uh they decided to keep me on uh with a
warning
i gotta say the initial message that ian
received
seems
not j it was very brief can you read it
i can pull it up uh but then the
follow-up message did seem kind of jokey
yeah that's what i was gonna say that
read that first message they sent you
the first message was was pretty why you
pulled that up listen for his comment
ethan just said
how does someone have time to listen to
a two-hour album when he regularly makes
podcasts surpassing the two-hour mark
yeah how does anybody have any time to
watch this podcast
well
okay fair enough no that's a that's such
a horrible argument because it's not
it's not an album it's we're not you
know they're not songs you put on a
podcast you listen to it at home at work
wherever you're at
okay he's right and nobody has time for
this [ __ ]
uh okay so the the message i got
from somebody said
dear ian
given your very recent comments on the
h3 podcast on the subject of kanye
west's latest album donda we will be
forced to reconsider your honorary
moderator status on r kanye thank you
for your understanding best the r slash
kanye mod team that is 100 serious yeah
i mean it doesn't come across as a joke
at all but his reply
after ian messaged them back was very
jokey so yeah they may have been [ __ ]
around the whole i think they were
goofing on me a little bit yeah but it
was a it was a subtle like
watch your mouth
watching a hot button i'm worried though
because are you gonna speak truth to
kanye or are you gonna be in fear of
losing your mod status
no i
i think i was
being pretty fair i complimented aspects
of the album there's a collection of
songs i like a lot so
you know i think it's okay to not have
to love
every single thing they don't they
disagree yeah well they were goofing a
little there's some uh
there's some offshoots that would
disagree with me but uh
i think the the kanye people on the
subreddit seem in uh good good spirits i
was also you know not to the extent of
ian but i was also getting messages
because i compliment or not complimented
i i talked about the mix of the record
how it's not up to par and people are
like who's your eq [ __ ] up
it's like no
well someone goes yeah another example
of ethan talking on something he doesn't
know about it's like bro i'm allowed to
not like you the [ __ ] music you like
dude you'd have to call and question my
whole existence as a person yeah i mean
he listened to the album like is that
not you know what i'm going to like it
too let's just let's just get this thing
down
[ __ ] me in the ass right let's just get
this thing down
all right where were we ian love is
getting arrested for doing too much
zoola interface wow
that'll put you away for life yeah
thank you for life my original caption
was when you get faked you get freaked
too hard yeah when you skip fika
when you skip fake ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
you hit him with that
i'm ready to let him go man
for life i can't take her face like that
to jail
it's not happening
and finally mine is um
breaking my vegan diet
very sorry guys
[Music]
under arrest by the vegan place
is that salami
oh
it reminds me of um sometimes you see
people getting arrested and they like
eat the drugs to remove the evidence oh
that's what you're doing you're trying
to get rid of that
real quick these videos will all be on
tick tock with the original sound i feel
like it gives a whole different meaning
to it with the bass drop i saw the light
yeah h3 podcast tick tock is all going
down
is our home it you god damn right it is
i'll be posting a picture of my [ __ ] on
a h3 podcast tick tock that's apparently
allowed
flash is not going anywhere flash only
torque
okay got it hey um
that was the last one right yeah okay so
i have some uh breaking news ahead is
relevant to what we were just discussing
earlier but
ian if you could punch this up please
um it looks like
our boy james
has
indeed
join the clergy
so wait he looks like he's even in like
a position of authority like he raised
the ranks quickly
yeah i mean is that a uh
is that cardinal's hat
i'm not familiar i'm not a
too familiar with the uh catholic
hierarchy it seems like he really fit in
there so right it seems like he
integrated really well
absolutely in common with them all well
god bless him and he raised the ranks
very quickly
i'm happy he's giving back he's on this
is yeah he's giving he's giving
something he's helping the kids
are we gonna get eviscerated for this
eviscerated how
why what do you mean by eviscerated
we're applauding him he is helping the
children this is a sacrifice okay he is
sacrificing himself sister sacrificed
oh my god this is the t and he's gonna
find a lot of like-minded individuals
there in the clergy that they can really
bond over so i'm happy about that right
he's our sister savior
right
sister uh
he got really sad
that little
click gets me every time
yeah if you're wondering if i feel bad
making fun of the catholic church i will
never
that that will never ever
ever
ever
but that's not what i'm doing
you know
congratulations james i'm glad you found
a better path
[Music]
oh cam says that this is he's the pope
this is the pope yo the pope
he was elected to pope yo the pope goes
purple that's a fire fit that was yeah a
little bit dude he got elected the pope
wow
stop the fear
he just
shot up game
time on his resume he's probably like
you know i like photos i shouldn't as
well you know it's just like people
oh how the pulp like the likes
are being informed that the pope wears
purple on easter but it was red
originally lol that is the message that
i just received so you know how like
when they're trying to come up with who
the next pope is and they burn the smoke
yep right were they burning james
charles pallets this time or
he was shedding his former self god he
was burning the palate the burning of
the palate
oh jesus
and actually he's volunteered
interestingly this is very uncommon for
the pulp to lead
the sunday
service the uh
the youth group so
it's nice of him to see the choir yeah
the choir he's a he's a choir leader
because you know he's passionate about
singing and stuff
it's nice here to death i don't know
it's nice
to get down with the with the lowly
speared to death
all right let's move on what's the worst
thing you've ever done oh my god
thank you thank you and congratulations
james oh god
you do we have a or maybe we can see him
as a scout a boy scout leader too
uh
i don't
um yeah maybe i mean he's the pope does
he really have time for that he he
midlines he does both he moves back
he works hard
were you ever in the boy scouts do you
ever do the boy scout thing that's not
like a jewish thing
that's not true at all really yeah my
because i did and there were a bunch of
jewish kids in like a real troop yeah
okay i'm not even on this none of the
jewish kids yeah my group was like 50
jewish it was all good really i never
knew any of my friends to do scott i
never did scouts no okay
i i did it for a couple years as a cub
scout a couple years
yeah i think like two three
how was it
to be honest i
had fun it was cool but it seems fun
except well so i did it when i was a cub
scout which is when you're like in
elementary school yeah and then you
graduate into the boy scouts and that's
where it goes down i guess
that's where it goes down
uh i i quit shortly after that because
you you graduate into that when you're
like 12 or 13 but you're in the group
with kids up to like 18 and i felt like
very out of place and intimidated as
soon as when i was at a cub scout
everybody was my age and then all of a
sudden i'm like hanging out with like
high school seniors
in the troop and i i just didn't vibe
with it the eagle scouts that's what
they're called the like top level ones
the eagle scout is like the the the top
thing yeah i knew a kid that became an
eagle scout
it's crazy cool cool man
no i'm just saying you put in that time
for that [ __ ] like what do you
accomplish you know that's [ __ ] sick
i mean i'm level i was level 70 on
everquest so
that's way more
hours put in like no hey you know
all right let's move on shall we
i now again okay so
um
i'm gonna talk about keemstar
real quick and i'm sorry and the discord
i found something you might want to see
thank you mm-hmm
we should open that
oh
i can't why can't i
here i got it right here
oh my god
he's a time traveler
he's not only as a time traveler but he
has one of the largest craniums yeah
that's a big one known to mankind he's
actually really old he's just good with
makeup so he yeah so looks like james
used to go camping with the kids
how old is this photograph
and um
it was their chaperone
oh
oh
i didn't realize there's a little
caption here too hi scouters
[Music]
there we go all right let's get let's
move on yes please
okay so i'm going to talk about keemstar
now obviously every time i talk about
keemstar he's writing an angry letter to
youtube as you guys know snitch star
karen starr
so i'm gonna keep this factual i'm not
gonna editorialize this at all
i feel very foolish i just want to keep
people um
updated on his
life
he is a public figure
and one that we care about and i just
want to keep people updated so i'm just
going to show this post without comment
okay
this is brantley my new personal
assistant to all you creeps and ladies
worried you lost your spot
i believe she's 20.
it was stated although i might be wrong
i just believe i remember reading that
can i i'll read comments i mean that's
not me
he's so cool dude
he's just so [ __ ] cool hanging out
with 20 year old girls all the time
yeah you should probably switch off of
it
yeah
i don't trust on comments
i mean checked
just so [ __ ] cool
that's my that's what is that your
commentary i think i'm just jealous that
he's so [ __ ] cool
so the top comment says are you driving
her to high school
that is what the comment says
that this is all public comments on
instagram so i'm not i don't even know
what's here yo
let's see what else okay can you not
thank you
um
wow they're making me read all the
responses keem what is going on with all
these way younger girls around you was
there no 30 year old assistant out there
that's a fair observation not my
observation very important stuff
keem just remember that's
what is idk i don't know
kim just remember that's i don't know
i don't know what that comment means
keem is winning yeah
you may want to pay her more she looks
pissed i feel very foolish
oh that's the continuous w h3 hates to
see
bro stay winning out there
steve bust it
here she is you know i'm not gonna show
her but anyway keemstar shout out stay
winning
cool dude
love him
it's the best
all right next segment we've got someone
that i think is going to be pretty fun
everybody
took a picture of their refrigerator
anonymously
we are going to put the picture of the
refrigerator on the screen
and we have to guess and analyze psycho
analyze whose refrigerator it is
based on
the content so how do i have this
picture i just open this uh uh you
should okay so pick one okay great
okay wow this is so interesting looking
at someone's refrigerator is so intimate
isn't it it's like
this is [ __ ] interesting
so let's take a look here we've got
barbecue sauce leftover chinese
cinnamon rolls
now now let me get some clarity sam
and ian live together is they counting
as one person there is one yeah they're
a unit
country croc
that's fake butter right
it's like good good
i think they have margarine margarine
right i guess
um they've got sriracha
what is this jug here what is this milk
or is this like soy milk that is almond
milk i believe okay almond milk
interesting
yogurt eggs i mean semen is it's another
kind of milk thank you
it's a pretty actually pretty vanilla
looking fridge what do you guys think
about this
are you guys not allowed to comment i
think you you have to
you have to make take the stab
all right it's not abs
[Music]
i think abe's fridge is more empty
zap so it would if it was zach's i know
zach's like super keto
is there anything here that would
dispute the keto diet not really
but for some reason i don't think this
is zach so just don't
who's involved in this can who whose
fridge is involved is cameron's in this
no it's just it's just us okay
cream cheese zach hates cream cheese i
recall
that was something that he stated
through despise it one of the weirdest
things ever
especially for a jew i was about to say
i'm a bad jew i feel like this has to be
ian and sam's fridge
[Music]
oh frogs that is my fridge my my oh i
forgot dan of course it's dan's [ __ ] you
forgot me no i for some reason i wasn't
even considering you
what the hell we love dan
what is this mango berry what is this
here
uh yeah it's frozen fruit to make
smoothies
that's a clean fridge my dude thanks for
i'm a wat idiot and you wait go back
real quick you see those uh paper bags
on the bottom right yeah that's hello
fresh if you'd like to get it you can go
to hellofresh.com
after dark 14.
14
uh 14 free meal up to 14 free meals all
right that's hellofresh.com after dark
14. thank you dan thank you dan
okay pretty clean i mean yeah this is an
adult refrigerator so that's why you
know what's interesting the zero
uh usage of the
bottom bins
yeah interesting fridge yeah
yeah what are those two big white jugs
that's almond milk you guys oh okay
but yeah no usage no fresh fruit it's a
lot of real estate man to tell you the
truth this this is actually relatively
empty in fact i think we have okay
well
does that really flex i don't know
mr grocery mr grocery i have a feeling
these other hooligans fridge is going to
be a much sorry stated yeah i i i took a
peep at these uh before the show and
there's definitely um there's yeah i'm
expecting some sorryness coming up
all right dan's
yeah nice job
but also you have like a gainfully
employed girlfriend who's also
responsible that's a responsible
person's fridge yeah
ali could probably take a lot of credit
for the state of the bridge i know that
man
okay wow interesting lots okay so moving
on to number two lots of sauces wow
this is all sauce sauce bottles this is
all sauce no food
taco sauce a lot of bernades sauce a lot
of bray got
what the [ __ ] has bri got
i'm wondering that myself there's a lot
of it though can someone google bariga
and define it for me bragat
why is there so much burrito there's a
lot of regular we got there's like three
times uh all bright products contain
fresh cream uh
excuse me
okay i'm just gonna say it rapeseed oil
uh and a pinch of salt for that
i know what rapeseed is rapes it's a
normal thing rapeseed oil they got to
rework that name though
i've never heard about the rape that
caught me off guard
i think it's the same as chronology yeah
okay okay
so it's like margarine or i guess it's
like a butter replacement
so somebody with some serious um
uh lactose intolerance i would say
wait oh this is obviously loves bruh
chocolat
okay so i got it right you're right you
almost got me i mean this what i really
didn't suspect
but there's a lot of [ __ ] here i never
seen or heard about a lot of taco sauce
just straight up yeah what's up salsa
oh it's salsa oh my god love i have a
question is that a drawer full of onions
yeah go to the bottom that's a lot of
onions
onions it's one bag
but that's like there's other what are
you doing
you love onions what do you do with all
those onions
um i don't know well i cook cooked food
do you
that's why i love always making that
face because the onions in the house
yo is this beer what is this can here oh
yeah that's some beer yeah oh you do a
little bit of trouble
you know what you're saying
is uh that first shelf look at the like
the head room on the on the bottom shelf
right yeah yeah that's pretty good
configuration that's some swedish fridge
[ __ ] right now
yeah i agree the the other fridge looks
super cramped so is this the fridge you
go to for the fika this is the fridge
well yeah there's also i didn't show the
freezer but there's a lot of features
it's just it's a lot of sauce yeah a lot
of sauce on the right my i live with my
dad oh it's like if he's crazy without
you okay so bean what is matt yes what
is this
oh that's uh
matt greta whip what maybe cool whip bro
you guys are killing it wait is it no
it's like food you're cooking oh it's
whipping cream whipping cream yeah oh
there you go food
got it
love that [ __ ]
yeah and at the top here top right
you guys don't have that sauce no okay
on the um on the top right shelf in the
middle
that's what i'm looking i know the
pineapple [ __ ] okay i guess the middle
this like
no left here
up up burning the yellow yeah what is it
yeah it's like the best sauce ever and
you guys and it doesn't exist outside of
sweden it's great sauce
i ate it to everything literally
i mean it's not a swedish thing but
i've traveled quite a bit and i always
ask for it and they don't have it what
does it taste like
isn't it similar to
its own thing isn't it similar to
hollandaise sauce like the stuff that
you get on like
can you say it no can you say it how do
you say it
beyonce
or band nice well you got three bars
sauce made of clarified butter
emulsified in egg yolks and white wine
vinegar and flavored with herbs oh
excuse me you shut me down real quick
love it is considered to be a child of
the mother hollandaise sauce
yeah i i
[Applause]
uh
i've only had hollandaise sauce on an
eggs benedict which is like an egg
sandwich basically um
so i
i really don't know
well a nice looking fridge but you do
live with your dad so i'm kind of i'm
you know that kind of like
yeah if you were by yourself what would
this fridge look like you know what i
mean
well
the same but without the sauce on the
right oh just sauce world would be out
of here
this looks like a pretty common swedish
fridge i think yeah you could have a
fika you could have a few figures in
here great figure friends
all righty thank you
moving on
wait this is just someone's freezer
oh it's i think it's two parts okay here
we this is interesting
all right moving on to part three
oh so the fridge is looking pretty bare
oh
ground chicken yeah i feel like this
one's obvious newman's own
[Music]
a jug of water
zach you like newman's own don't you
i've heard you say that
[Music]
this
this is this is obvious this is zach's
pizza rolls that's not keto dude oh i
see a lot of meat in here though
that's what
that was
setting me off is just the amount of
meat in this bridge freezer's full of
meat
there's lots of meat in the fridge
tortillas which pizza rolls
zach you you want
i mean i i don't eat those oh it's sax
gotcha
[Music]
yeah was that the girlfriends or
something yeah she's about the pizza
rolls yeah that's a game this is like
that divorced dad
yeah
this is a i mean he's a young man in his
early 20s i'll be honest i've seen
there's been times in my life where i've
had a worse looking fridges than this
yeah it's all the essentials i mean
it's not that bad
and it's clean you know i'm not stocked
up with [ __ ] um hollandaise sauce but
yeah
yeah what's this roll back here behind
the pizza rolls wait hold on let me look
it's like a
meat tube oh it's um ground chicken wait
is your is your ice tray completely full
of otter pops yeah that's [ __ ] epic
dude we buy them on amazon like you just
use them for ice like that's how you
cool down your drinks you just stick an
otter pop in there well there's an ice
train there somewhere but um
yeah otter pops are [ __ ] i'm water
bots are fired [ __ ] love otter pops
so much
somebody here didn't know what otter
pops were
was it uab i yeah i've never heard of i
know what they are but i've never heard
them maybe it's a regional thing called
water pops here
they're pretty low calorie um
yeah and you know it's a nice dessert
after dinner all right it's refreshing
very good not bad i gotta say not bad
thank you
i mean it's a little sparse but right
and then it's all there right you know
no bottom right drawer is pretty empty
all right come moving on to number four
what the [ __ ] is this this is so okay
wow the spices that is well organized
yeah this is
this is obvious
it's almost there's three pictures by
the way so there's tahini like shitload
of tahini that's a dead giveaway
tons of milk
here's the refrigerator itself damn a
three-parter
yeah it's a three-parter there's only
there's only one person here whose
fridge would need three three uh
photographs to contain it all well
that's the freezer
look at all those fruit containers ready
to be left out
where
how dare you i'm never mind they're not
there they're here
this is obviously ethan's yeah this is
my fridge
it's a good it's a great look a massive
amount of tahini is [ __ ] well yeah
when i took that picture i was like oh
this is so obvious because
i don't know why there's like a shitload
of tahini here
a lot of this [ __ ] i could throw out
though
is all old [ __ ]
makes for good fika
the milk obviously for theodore
right right
you know
and it's a big ass fridge
that's the other giveaway the
three-parter dude you need three photos
to get
all right moving on
yep
is this this is uh
this is part how many eggs we got hold
on this is two parts so we've got how
many eggs do we need we have three
cartons of eggs and maybe more
underneath yeah is that also eggs it
looks like oh no
this is garlic that's garlic a baker
someone likes to bake
interesting yeah the hypothesis well and
corn
someone that likes to cook i'm noticing
people are really not drinking milk
these days all of us so far have had
almond milk oat milk
you know the only reason i have milk is
for theodore is this kind of
psychopathic to drink milk as an adult i
feel like
uh he just defended the whole sweet
swedish continent
i feel like it's just i don't know it's
falling out of
style
well
so there's only two people left
and
i actually
it's by the power of deduction that i
know that this is ian and sam's because
i have a feeling that abs is going to be
a lot more sparse than this
excuse me this is i'll have you know
chocolate m ms
ground turkey
lots of fresh produce
i mean that's good this is a healthy
this is a healthy fridge the eggs i mean
a little weirded out by the amount
this is someone who orders out a lot
though because there's not really like
meals here going on yeah there's got to
be ian and sam
yes it is ours that's right also i gotta
say very impressed with the refrigerator
so far you guys really have your [ __ ]
together now there were
a freezer is i am so embarrassed you
guys are overwhelmed with frozen goods
yeah we got some stuff we gotta throw
out i look at this now we make smoothies
and so it's a lot of frozen fruit
say i'm talking about
i see frozen peppers a lot of frozen
fruit we make smoothies a lot yeah yeah
where's reuben's food does he got uh he
has his own drawer oh he has a feeker
drawer
so okay
very impressed so far i mean so this
one's obviously yep there
that's what this is this is the one this
is the one i was waiting for
ab
a dead giveaway
now that's a divorce bad for you you
like that [ __ ] i hate lebanese lemonade
yeah dude it's like sour right bitter
weird ass cheese
hold on you're disrespecting a whole
culture right now we love lebanese
yeah i gave sam some to go home well did
you try it
me oh i love this stuff really i used to
eat it like religiously i love it what
does it taste like what is it [ __ ]
kind of like a yogurty yeah i don't know
it's
pita bread no no no no it's it's thick
it's like cream cheese but it's super
sour and just horrific it's like acidy
and sour
oh my god but you you it's like exactly
you you dip with it right like you it's
yeah the spread the spread right so abi
i get asked what's like an average
dinner for you and you know lebanese
that's what you that's why you're so
skinny yeah i was about to say how do
you think amazing
we eat out a lot but also we spend so
much time at work now that we're you're
not uh the freezer it's freezer your
freezer is empty dude the freezer is
dead empty except for one item what is
this item that would be fish sticks
yeah there you go but uh this is the one
i was waiting damn bro
that's rough it's clean at least it is
clean thank you might well turn it off
to save some energy oh that that reminds
me yes the light bulb is dead it's been
dead for months and i keep forgetting to
change it oat milk once again proving my
theory that only psychopath thick adults
drink milk sorry love actually you know
what in l in sweden i'll tell you people
in sweden like almost nobody is lactose
intolerant in sweden
like
oh you are oh well yeah oh well
[ __ ] me in there i drink it anyway
because everyone like forces on me so
what happens when you drink it
it farts a lot
you just get gassy
no there there's actually like pills you
can eat so i supplement my
stomach with the protein needed so i can
drink it so what happens if you just if
you take milk is it gassy or is it like
toilet just
one week of hell
one oh my goodness
yeah so i just take a pill
before each meal and you're good that's
faked up dude
yeah
yeah when we didn't find any lemony out
here for like a few months actually no
like six months we lived out here with
no lebanon then when we found it in the
grocery store lena legit like almost
teared up i have a video really
somewhere but i can't that's funny has
the same kind of where she's looking for
her
i wonder whose this is uh no idea
that's oliver twist
this [ __ ] live streamed him
jumping on the fridge cameron you're not
supposed to appear in your picture
yeah that kind of
that kind of gives it away i didn't
realize it was on the top of the
refrigerator it was just kind of a
goofing example just a little goose is
this all yours because i know you're
right now doing like an airbnb situation
right
this is all yours
okay it is not all is any of it yours
uh yeah i mean the middle rose kind of
mind it kind of it's kind of like split
up but
is that your cold stone creamery
uh no that is not damn dude they're
stocked up yo look at this what is this
oh is this coffee it's probably coffee
wait is this you your old place yeah
this is my old place but i uh i just
threw this in as a goof as they say okay
this is just a goop yeah just a little
just a little goof for you
well there you have it folks abey's
fridge did not disappoint he abu you
have like a drink fridge too right like
a uh wine rack i do yeah we put water
bottles in there cause we're keeping it
hello you should uh convert your main
fridge into just like a wardrobe or
something yeah some extra storage that's
true
well thank you everyone for sharing no
uh no horror stories though i don't know
if that's where you're overall very
impressed with clean well-organized
refrigerators i think we have some
well-adjusted adults here in this
assuming nobody's cheated
no i don't think so i don't think anyone
would cheat like that
refrigerator is everything
refrigerator is astronomical
and yet like i still open the fridge and
i have no [ __ ] idea what to eat every
day
every day
all the time i don't have that problem i
open it i'm like do i want lemonade i'm
good do you get sick of it ever no
never you gotta you know what bring it
in so that all the guys can taste it
okay bring it in on friday
lebanese hit me with that lemonade you
got it
do you like that like salty yogurt drink
no um
uh lena does uh leban uh
what the oh my god i'm disappointing
everyone right now it's a yogurt drink
that looks like it would be sweet it's
like
lemon but it's salty
i think it's called leban
what are you saying love
was that it no
okay
oh thank you thank you peace and love
peace and love peace and love
all right and you know
finally we have a little bit of a update
we've done content courts
on both the prince family
and the ace family
and there was a tweet i made okay so
this is fake okay fine i'll show you the
tweet
and it made me really interested to do a
follow-up
on the prince family these guys
my mouth ugh my thing is flipped oh
so check this out cps took our kids from
a seafood boil mukbang
so dan were you the one that confirmed
that it was fake because i was seeing
this all over reddit i didn't know if
they maybe well i went to their channel
and it wasn't there unless they deleted
it can you show it ian i don't think we
saw it there we go can you guys fact
check and find out if this really
because like i totally believe that this
is a real title they would use
i totally believe based off of the other
ones it is believable but i i searched
through their channels as some of the
other yeah there are
pulled from their channel
[Laughter]
cps took and i don't see anyone in the
comments saying it's fake either so
these this is a family the prince family
who does this
the most horrific click bait on their
kids that i've ever seen
wait so i just looked up that title and
there's there's a there is a youtube
video cps almost took our kids seafood
boyle mukbang but it's not the prince
family wait who is it
kevin on stage studios is that a guy it
sounds like a joke maybe
i guess
i found a reddit thread under that photo
and uh it links a youtube video and it's
unavailable been removed by uploader so
here here here maybe they did and they
deleted the story okay that video was
posted two years ago they've changed the
title on the thumbnail since then
so but this was real
oh wow
so
yeah this okay okay i mean i believe it
like i believed it initially because
like you said i mean they they have
other ones that are this bad if not
worse so and i just couldn't find that
video check in on them we're gonna check
on the prince family and the ace family
and do a battle
of the youtube families
which one is more offensive and i feel
like there's no contest here
yeah it's kind of a blowout all right so
looking over the prince family
we've put together
some of their recent thumbnails this is
all stuff that you can find on their
channel
uh right now
and
bro
this [ __ ] is
next level disturbing
so here this one is from three days ago
bianca took the kids and left me please
come
and of course it's all clickbait right
like no this shit's true yeah
i miss my family
clickbait you believe that [ __ ]
look at this i don't know how this [ __ ]
gets any views like this is the most
horrific
disgusting freak thumbnail i've ever
seen in my life i hate this one so much
it's so [ __ ] up i got infected from
going out of the country
yep
and this is like
what's that uh there's like a trick to
phobia phobia
yeah i have that well i didn't know i
had it but now i do have it now
looking at you
it's so
[ __ ] disgusting oh
god of course it's fake all fake
this one is next mother loving lover
preparing for a home water birth
she is giving birth dude these guys are
on a whole nebular level
come on man
um my god
this is for me when it gets too much
they're putting kids or their pictures
of their kids
yeah and that i'm not the father here is
a dna test with this baby
dna result shows that damien is not the
biological father that's fake right i
mean it's all fake yeah yes she cheated
on me
come on dude is clickbaiting the
paternity with a picture of his actual
child
yeah there was a there was a birth from
content court
um you sent me that a b yeah
it was titled her water broke right oh
right oh my god this is one we reviewed
on the content court on the content card
so they're still like gush
oh god
why
by the way i've seen the water break
it's not like uh fl it's not like a
oh it's not like a water balloon just
not a pot
no they're like yeah i think they were
like is that water
oh yeah they just spilled water right
everybody watched it he literally just
spilled a little water on the floor
amazing
and look at his hand he's like come on
all over the floor
i love that
yeah so um and then you know cl this is
unforgivable in my opinion this is like
putting his kid in the thumbnail with a
black eye
dangerous mosquitoes
we had to take him to the hospital all
fake
and it's like oh god i i find this to be
just unforgivably disgusting
this is just horrific i don't know how
to put into words how disgusting this is
why would you edit your child with
injuries and clickbait them going to the
hospitals just i need help it says
that's true you do need
a big lie
i'm a bodybuilder now i mean this one's
not that bad
yeah it's just the juxtaposition of
being a family channel with
i suppose that's true
i mean compared to this bro yeah right
i don't know how you do i don't know how
you sleep doing this to your kids
um here he got
emergency surgery please pray for us
this was about his hairline surgery i
believe but he looks like he has bullet
rolling shots in his head
ah these guys are so committed to the
clickbait
you have i would say you have to respect
it although i don't like the involvement
of the children
yeah i don't respect this
look at this one
she had an allergic reaction permanent
damage um
she's at the dentist before and after
she has been on meth for 20 years
[Laughter]
i mean
what the [ __ ] girl you are out of your
mind put that on it on a thumbnail
more trick to phobia [ __ ] oh god
no it's just terrific and by the way
four months ago this has four million
views i don't know who would click this
i mean this is
this to me is click repellent like i
can't stand looking at that and what's
crazy is that their like ratios and
their comments are always great like
nobody
minds so this one he click baited okay
get ready for this his dad dying
the thumbnail says i don't have much
time left with him with his dad
face to face with my dad for the first
time his dad he clickbaited his dad
dying ladies and gentlemen
so
there's that
there's that
oh my god you guys they clickbait their
son drowning
this is the second time they've done
this
bianca saved kiri from drowning and
here's their son dying in the pool as
the mom scoops him out kyrie yeah i mean
4.2 million views eight months ago
i'm sorry but
this is [ __ ] disgusting freak
behavior
bro i can't do it
come on man
come on man indeed and okay
what happened to nova's face their
daughter
who appears to be about like three four
five he says he took worms out of her
[ __ ] face
he took worms out of her face that's the
clickbait
god there's a handful of they make like
her eyes bloodshot and she's crying
you can't do that you guys help me daddy
it says
you should be so deeply ashamed
of what you're doing
i want
[Music]
shame i'm speechless shame
shame
this is the same one twice uh abe liked
it so much you put it in twice yeah it's
another look what does it mean that you
put this in twice
the bodybuilder one
yeah baby when'd you do that
uh it's distracting i don't know i got
it
i am an ass man yes
i couldn't have guessed
watch it's just there again
oh look at this man this is my favorite
bianca fell off a mountain hawaii
looks like she's falling into a volcano
actually he's falling off a cliff uh to
her definite or certain death help me oh
she's in mordor
yeah
and what what actually happened in the
video she probably like stubbed she
would probably like
stubble tripled tripped a little bit is
that the same hand
are they using the same png of his arm
reaching out oh
oh
you're right you just passed it you're
like no no i was looking there's the one
where his wife where he's like come on
how'd you break your water all over the
floor i said
yeah this was a last minute suggestion
i'd actually watched this one but
she's still alive so
okay that's good yeah it's [ __ ]
one of these days something tragic is
gonna happen and they're gonna clickbait
it like my wife died and she really died
that'd be [ __ ] awesome
that's
crazy
guys she really did fall off a cliff
so wait did her daughter really lose
hearing because here they click baited
her with a hearing aid okay so she
did have uh hearing problems in one ear
that she inherited from her mother
um
but they made multiple videos about it
and uh
yeah it's never mind i'm not i mean take
it alone that wouldn't
be that
bad of a thing you know but
in lieu of all this other clickbait i
have a feeling that
they are exaggerating
well i don't yeah i was hesitant to say
it but it does sound awfully
like the plot of creed 2
where the bundler has a hearing problem
and gives birth to a child with a
hearing problem wait the mother feels
horrible about
yeah i don't think this one feels bad
about anything maybe the the baby tested
positive for something called cmv which
um
affected their hearing
okay so
someone's fine there's some legitimacy
today yeah
fair enough
i mean i wouldn't be surprised if they
just made this [ __ ] up though arya
aliyah lost her hearing
she's just fine
it'd be like it'd just be her being like
oh yeah and she didn't answer right away
pretty much i mean they're like it's
weird the way they're hold the baby's
like dead asleep and she's like crying
holding the baby in the beginning of the
video and i don't know it's just these
people are
no shame
man
and then of course we go back to where
we started which is maybe the best
thumbnail title i've ever seen in
youtube history
cps took our kids from us seafood boiled
mukbang heartbreak heartbreaking emoji i
love the juxtaposition of cps took our
kids plus seafood
still blown away that that's real
goodbye dinner
well hey at least now we got more we got
more money for mukbangs i mean kids eat
a lot so more for us there you go
yo when cps takes your kids every meal
is a mukbang
in a way
you know you get through all the gerber
you make with the dinner for four
or five i don't know
clear out the pantry of all that gerber
you got stocked up yeah should i just
say before the comment warriors come at
us that i i know cmv can potentially be
serious it could lead to serious
diseases and disorders but
way too late for that dude i'm just
saying the fact that they're
broadcasting in the way that they're
doing it is so distasteful i wouldn't
have included these two to be honest
with you
i guess when you see the video it yeah
like i said those are standalone things
not
not a big deal but especially compared
to the consideration of all this other
[ __ ] right totally understand why you
included it right
i think you're fine
shame
shame give me a really good i mean they
click baited their their their child
drowning bro yeah exactly you know what
i mean like uh i mean every week it's
something our secret daughters the
episode one of their videos the name of
one of their videos our secret daughter
oh really yeah and what's the res and
what's the truth behind it oh i i didn't
watch that one there's too many there's
way there's here let me go to their
channel actually let's just get a free
flow of
ace family or no here's a little
background actually um
the prince family's head writer
uh for their channel oh is that j
station that it sure is
yeah it on that makes sense actually
yeah
my dream car got repossessed
sonic.exe guys
[Laughter]
um
damn they get hella views yeah they get
hella views it's awesome
she got really sick in hawaii my real
dad versus my stepdad fight
kinda epic
can't play it it's cursed
[Music]
what the frick what the freak
shout out to jstation now a virulent
anti-vaxxer by the way
sonic.exe
he's going for that bandsaw yeah it's
hard to see they have so much content
it's hard to pick out the really
horrific
i think you grab the good ones yeah
i mean some are just gross but you know
the further back you go it's like i feel
like the worse it gets too please no
more small holes i i the small holes
oh we moved out of state our kids can't
come home that's a good one
new house tour
we moved out of state our kids can't
come home that sounds tragic let's watch
what the first moment's like
as a side note bianca was uh banned from
tick-tock
really yeah she said people just keep
reporting her videos but from what i saw
all she was doing was dancing but was
she thirst trapping
i guess you could say that i think
because you have to be pretty obscene on
tick-tock to get banned i feel like for
thirst trapping yeah
maybe they just didn't like her voice
because she did do the bianca thing here
they clickbait their house burning down
their house burning down pray for the
prince family
their house burned down
because you're not sure exactly where
it's coming from okay
that puts these pipes on that pipe is
our burst so we can't why does the sauce
feel fake so we can't put super glue on
it bro oh there's a water leak there's a
[ __ ] water leak
and they click baited their house
burning down you guys it's the opposite
of their house burning down really
hang on i can actually close the window
oh
god i'm actually enjoying looking
through these thumbnails man these are
pretty amazing
oh we got her tick tock yeah i want to
see what kind of
love says she's not banned
she was man they made a video about it
too oh well surprise surprise oh you got
clickbaited baby
yeah
yeah
you got got bro
yo you got a lot of views on tick tock
she got you
i can't believe you fell for that what
the freak no i told you i swear the page
i was looking at wasn't there staring at
another girl's ass
oh she's doing the cheating
the cheating other girls bikini posts
having a girl best friend
keeping other girls nudes
flirting with other girls
hanging out with another girl one-on-one
constantly texting other girls
calls other girls pretty
is friends with someone who likes him
goes to a party without saying anything
to you
having a fortnight duo partner being a
girl
cheating cheating you're not cheating
she said not on that one
she seemed uh
you know her answers were pretty fair
fortnite
she secure uh let's see here we've got
she can hear shocking
yeah
oh my god this thumbnail
bro that thumbnail
[Laughter]
um
she's drowning
we're going broke
the truth
the truth and it's her his daughter
going dead
that are we broke
daddy
yes baby
we're not gonna be able to eat anymore
yeah this [ __ ] is shameless freak
behavior love me daddy so anyway that
that's what the prince family's up to
nothing's changed over there by the look
of it not really
ace family i'll be honest
their channel is pretty clean like at
face value right i mean here let's go
over to their thumbnails yeah i tried to
you know
find something equivalent to this over
there and they're
they're a lot more respectable not yeah
they're made up obviously austin there's
no my daughter drowned or exactly
my wife fell off a cliff for real
into a volcano
like that but
there is some really funny stuff going
on with his wife
who uh announced that she is making her
own channel
so for anyone interested in catherine
mcbroom's new channel here's some of the
topics you guys ready for this
[Music]
she's got god purpose third eye
okay
right
ancestors trauma and then well if you go
down a little bit here's my favorite
quantum physics you guys
[Laughter]
she's going to be talking about quantum
physics
yeah that's one small step for
third eye and quantum physics absolutely
sleep paralysis manifestation ayahuasca
really oh [ __ ] really yeah those
[ __ ] get up to ayahuasca over
there at the ace family thanks and wild
out
oracle
oracle deck hall
um yeah i appreciate someone that could
skip from clothing halls
to uh
astrophysics though
here's what's her what's her knowledge
base there what what does she think
about the
the the dark matter
problem you know what's what's her
thoughts on darth vader
thoughts on black holes huh
i think she's gonna be in the
spider-verse movie pretty sure i'm
pretty sure she i'm pretty sure um
she's in close proximity to a black hole
in austin's chest so
black hole saying he has no heart he has
a black hole for a heart wow
that's deep thank you
i think that's what she meant by yeah
astrophysics quantum physics actually
excuse me yeah we're talking the realm
of the of the small here ethan
yeah here's some yeah
i mean they clickbaited them breaking up
you know it's really not the same level
so i would say in the battle of the
families
yeah i mean that's vanilla compared to
what we were just looking at 100
without a doubt the worst and most
shameless click baiting i've ever seen
all my time on youtube goes without a
doubt to the prince family
so
in celebration can i get zach to just
give us one
real good long
it's your girl bianca here we go in
celebration let's go
what you got for me for those that don't
know this is what um she says at the
beginning of all the ace family you guys
are the prince prince family friends
friends family
guys ready
the mongolian throat singer how she
rotates
wow wow give it up
give it up for bianca
[Laughter]
modern day here's johnny yeah well after
we did that content chord i was i was
doing that for a long time
yeah there's a there's an ancient
technique called where the mongolian
throat singers they can breathe in while
they exhale well she can do it too yeah
that's what i'm saying
oh there she goes
we had somebody call in once
who knew how to do it right yeah he
taught me how to do it here yeah dude
that's what the horns on judgement day
are going to sound like
bianca
[Music]
no
oh bianca what's happening
she's got a little laryngitis yeah
all right well oh real quick um yeah
it looks like we have the debut of
catherine mcbroom's channel
and apparently she's actually taking on
the role of doctor strange in the
multiverse
ace family oh because she's quantum
she's she's she's in the realm now well
if you combine the third eye with
quantum physics right i think you get uh
dr uh
uh mcbroom this is the first time for me
in the marvel universe now cam i have to
say um
i believe it is ant-man that actually
has the quantum powers not uh doctor
strange so if you could take this back
to the drawing board and um give us a
revision here
thank you well
yeah i'm not going to debate on that
yes ant-man travels to the quantum realm
i think doctor strange also can access
the quantum realm i mean it's
presumptuous for you to assume
no he deals more in
alternative space
dimensions he can hop dimensions but the
quantum realm is the real dimension it's
not a dimension it's it's the the realm
of the tiny of the very small
doctor strange can [ __ ] with the quantum
[ __ ] bro can somebody
you know what
i know there's a story i know there's a
cross i don't even like the marvel the
marvel stuff i don't know why i'm
can dr strange
reach
the quantum realm let's see what google
has to say
oh
uh
as mordo explained to doctor strange
when he was training him in the use of
the sling ring they allow us to travel
through the multiverse doctor strange
should be able to enter the quantum
realm itself
by use of the sling ring so really is
that the the sling ring it's part of the
lore baby
how dare you the marvel you know this is
the first time for me in the quantum
realm
in the marvel universe we all got we all
got our otter pops
yeah found out we had some in the
freezer
kind of awesome time to uh sign off here
yep
i'm so sad
that our [ __ ]
h3 tv is still down i mean like this is
just
it's outrageous
injustice on a whole new level it's an
outrage should we talk about joe rogan
getting horse d warmer or save that
let's save it
some breaking news while we're recording
this episode is that joe rogan has
announced that he has coveted and that
he is you talk horse team warmer well
he said he took ivermectron or whatever
which i'm not a doctor
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what horses take when they have
worms there is a human there is a human
version of it joe rogan took it to
kyrskovic guys how much do you take of
that
about enough to kill a elephant
five percent means everything oh he took
he took five five percent of the two
five percent now if he took to five
percent of enough to kill an elephant
then he'd be fine five percent
difference is astronomical
he takes that five percent
he takes that five percent all right
guys that's enough for today
i'm really
babysat
all right
um we will be back on
friday baby
and then [ __ ] yeah next week guys i
can't emphasize this enough four
episodes also
you
told me that you would like
to start doing h3tv on tuesday instead
of monday because we can never
stick to anything i didn't say that yes
you did you told me that you would you
thinking we should do it on tuesday i
would make to clarify okay he said just
this upcoming week because of labor day
correct that is oh maybe i
misinterpreted everything i think it
would be nice if we had a three-day
weekend oh wow i didn't realize it was
labor day what kind of socialist am i
that doesn't know labor day
seriously pathetic fake ass socialist
[ __ ]
faker no but i also think like
eventually once we get the fourth show
nailed down it'd be cool if we did h3tv
on monday and tuesday and then we'd be
at the
golden five episode five episodes a week
ethan
putin he's been
asking me to do that for like three
years now
yeah it's been a slow steady climb so i
think once we get comfortable with four
we can we can go up to the coveted five
let's go
yeah let's go dan good luck
i'm so pissed i'm so you guys don't
understand
how [ __ ] annoying this is for me yeah
it's just it's injustice i'm livid
because you said some really nice things
about me during that episode and i
wanted to go home and rewatch it at
night you know
and download it and just listen to it
and i couldn't it's gone
that's a shame
probably never say another nice word
yeah that was it it may be the one and
only that's all you get you'll ever hear
something nice for me god damn it
what do you guys think about this look
for me should i just keep rocking the
chain in the yellow glass lucky you look
like ll uh cool j look cool i look cool
jay yeah yeah a little in the 80s rocked
a big gold chains right i was like more
like mr t
that's cool too you look like l.l
gj
[Music]
i bask in the laughter got him
all right let's sign off okay
oh one quick um
yeah so just a quick reminder that
triller is a one i gave trailer one star
here we go and um you can too share your
experiences
if you download the app and give
an honest view of your experience yeah
yo triller my thing's flipped
it's so flipped all right guys thank you
so much thank you thank you peace and
love will see you on friday
[Music]